hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay um we got a
thingy here and a thingy here and a
thingy there so we put the thingy in the
other thingy and boom all the thing he
goes to the thingy and then we're all
good there we are we good
I don't know who cares whatever as long
as I got my chair
uh-huh hunting up up a floor and I'm not
going to do it ass gets back
ah today ah come on I was trying to was
trying to cut the arm and grab a Duke
well that's a good start
oh god I'm all the way back here well
I'm all the way back here shut up
condescending tip I know stasis of
whatever whatever oh yeah I'm gonna use
the the flamethrower his people were
getting annoying I bought it I should
use it I'll use it when I'm good and
ready
I just happened to be using it now
whatever don't judge me okay thinking
the thingy and then the thing he goes to
the thingy and it shares we're
completely useless open oh look at it ah
I to pull with it switch with oh you a
punk
yeah
you go who's whoosh fire fire [ __ ] oh
there we go that's more like it
you dead he actually did aah
I will okay
exactly okay that looks easy all looks
good the stasis recharge right by oh oh
by the way guys how do you like my beard
growing it growing it for you guys this
is like five two gigs worth of dripper
for me
walk that was ill time come on
really really dry mini Christmas there
we go
now row whoa
okay I got away
oh yeah it's a good way I guess this
flamethrower killed him off booty cry
better for the little guys though that's
whatever what ever naka care ah
I'll hold off until I see some little
guys I'll be out of here but until I'm
ready
we got plenty of ammo OOP even more ammo
what I get security suit
hey there you're not going to do the
level-1 level-2 thing whatever on
No whoo awesome huh
nope
I mean I really expected like Oh sis
wanna [ __ ] ah what the hell
hi I'm a bit e e oh okay he's crazy
alright so Isaac's totally losing his
mind apparently freaky was that ah so is
Nicole trying to kill him threw him her
uh what Dom matter doesn't matter what
what was I saying I don't know something
about those tubes I was expecting
something to happen hmm
are you not you my god
okay that goes back the other way that I
came
what was that
what very dark uh-huh
oh I see good evening ah so smart
who's out there anybody more goodies
over there
yeah power node Oh awesome epic whoop
cells waste ammo whatever go down that
way okay I just noticed the the Waypoint
is curvy
who's out there Oh huh whoa huh okay
no one
huh
Oh ha ha bow that Darth bit I'm there to
join us is to certain five that's like
some weird bird
date on lockdown oh no or something in
the church iam broke the door hang on
I'll try to avoid all the gates in the
area huh Oh fried off
huh-huh-huh I saw you ah where are you
what the hell
ah ah - whoo you can call my health wise
are your legs off first
okay okay
jerk ha cigarette oh I can shoot your
talk
what oh yeah hold you I what the hell
get back here got another claw oh I see
you playing peek-a-boo huh oh oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah girl
there we go dead what the hell was that
huh
hey there
can you do anything from your ring let
me see what I can do
let me see what I can do better you go
through the FINA rearing of the church
and down to the croute very important
here not oh not in here of course as
soon as they say something important
it immediately cuts off man that son of
a [ __ ] hit me once
oh well tis the way of things
oh yeah super epic be packing oh so
great yeah oh yeah
I guess that's all of those guys for now
don't rush up oh by the way guys oh I
wanted to mention sorry I only uploaded
one video yesterday it was the only
video that I had already recorded and I
was a little bit hungover because my
stupid friend friend made me take shots
of Bacardi 151 with him
come on friends don't let friends do
that I did him down like I slammed him
down like a boss conduit room another
conduit room I want to go in the condo
can I go in the gutter yeah if you ever
get a chance to take a shot of 151 for
those of you who are old enough to drink
don't do it may sound like fun actually
doesn't sound like fun at all that's
dead donkey Bob wait where am I going
I don't even know in the right way did I
get anything back about going Oh
different no trust you
no justice no justice when I pick up the
damn ah not the head ah Wow perfect time
for fire
ah no no no aah fire I'm out of fire mo
aah
it's on me how did he not kill all those
things oh my god there's hundreds of
them aah fire was useless probably goes
aiming at the big guys another new one
Oh more fire juice ha ha
and what's this I got body alone whoa
an amount of her juice huh tada
what Harriet another one come on all
right are we done we done now we're done
with all the little goofy dance whatever
all this is really good chapel or
something
oh this is a funeral service that got
interrupted
is it less okay whatever whatever oh
hello yes please oh is that a bronze one
again what are you no ah
I thought so uh-oh this that one it's so
dark in here
said a bronze one again oh it's a gold
one okay huzza better
oh yeah the security seat all right I
guess that's okay yeah all right on
earth Oh zombie yeah get out here let
out a little anger Isaac I know it's a
frustrating situation all right what do
we got
ah try some debt in there I like me some
Dettol Nate Hall there was some maybe I
should play the whole game with just a
detonator huh Oh the detonator would
have been great for those fast charging
guys I got laid out traps and they would
have blown themselves to smithereens oh
I thought those raindrops looks like
little squiggly news oh that's me using
my noggin Chapter five
rolling right along these chapters are
short like way shorter than in Dead
Space 1 is that thing me it seemed to me
like in Dead Space 1 the chapters are
like quick get longer but I seem to be
flying through this oh yeah this is this
is good room full of dead bodies and
okay item Oh fire juice I don't really
like the fire thing flamethrowers is
called to me is not that Oh fun escape
did Oh
well that was freaky how's that so Isaac
seem to be going a lot more crazy than
he did in the last game Oh like
ridiculously more crazy
there's like 10 times crazy level all
right
that's all the time I got for this part
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part
bye bye